Optimal like this altitude.
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
Books.
I've loved on the Tim Ferriss show is exclusively brought to you by audible.
There couldn't be a better sponsor for this series.
My dear listeners and readers I've used audible for so many years,
as long as I can remember. I love it.
Audible has the largest selection of audio books on the planet.
I listen when I'm taking walks. I listen while I'm cooking.
I listen whenever I can. And if you're looking for a place to start,
I can recommend three of my favorites.
The first is the Tao of Seneca by Seneca.
If you want to hear my favorite letters of all time touches on stoic philosophy,
calmness under duress, et cetera.
The next is the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman,
G a I M a N one of my favorites,
even if you're a nonfiction purist,
this is the fiction book that you need to listen to.
Neo also has perhaps the most calming voice of all time and third,
Greg McKeown's essential ism subtitle.
The disciplined pursuit of less.
This is one of my favorite books of the past few years combines very well with
the 80 20 principle, but more on audible every month.
Audible members get one credit for any audio book on the site,
plus a choice of multiple audible originals from a rotating selection.
They also get access to daily news digests from the likes of the New York times
wall street journal and the Washington post as well as guided meditation
programs. And here are some other amazing audible features.
And I use a bunch of these. You can download titles and listen offline anytime,
anywhere I use this feature,
even when I could get access, I'll put my phone on say airplane mode,
because I don't want to get bothered with notifications.
And I'm taking a walk to clear my head and you can listen to titles offline in a
case like that or on a plane or whatever.
Obviously I'm not flying much these days.
The app is free and can be installed on all smartphones and tablets.
You can listen across devices without losing your spot.
And whisper sync is another feature I use quite a lot.
I love reading my Kindle in bed. For instance,
then picking up at the same exact spot where I left off.
When I go walking and listening to the next day,
Kindle and audio versions can be sinked up automatically is just amazing.
And if you can't decide what to listen to, don't sweat it.
You don't have to rush.
You can keep your credits for up to a year and use them for instance,
to binge on a whole series. If you like audible offers just about everything.
Podcasts, guided wellness programs, theatrical performances, alias comedy,
and audible originals. You won't find anywhere else.
And right now audible is offering you guys.
That's Tim Ferriss show listeners a free audio book with a 30 day
membership. And, uh, again, my list, if you want to check them out,
the town of Seneca, the graveyard book, essential ism,
those are just three there's so many good ones out there.
Just go to audible.com/tim and browse the unmatched
selection of audio programs. Then download your free title and start listening.
It's that easy? Just check it out.
Go to audible.com/tim or text Tim T I M
to 500, 500 to get started today. Check it out.
audible.com/tim.
Hello, boys and girls, ladies and germs. This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show,
where it is usually my job to sit down with world-class performers of all
different types, startup founders, investors, chess champions, Olympic athletes,
you name it to tease out that habits that you can apply in your own lives.
This episode, however,
is an experiment and part of a short form series that I'm doing simply
called books. I've loved. I've invited some amazing past guests,
close friends and new faces to share their favorite books.
Describe their favorite books. The books that have influenced them,
changed them, transform them for the better.
And I hope you pick up one or two new mentors in the form of books from this new
series and apply the lessons in your own life.
I had a lot of fun putting this together,
inviting these people to participate and have learned so so much myself.
I hope that is also the case for you. Please enjoy.
My name is Anna bottle.
I'm a writer and the founder of an organization called the school of life
dedicated to emotional fulfillment. And self-understanding,
I want to talk about two books today.
That mean a huge amount to me and that I always press into the hands of pretty
much anyone that I meet.
The first book is called home is where we start from.
And it's a collection of essays by wonderful English psychoanalyst called Donald
Winnicott. And Winnicott is wise on so many fronts,
but two of his ideas stand out in particular.
The first of his ideas concerns what he calls the true and the false
self for Winnicott.
All babies are born with a capacity to express Winnicott's
true self. In other words, to express themselves fully. And without inhibition,
if they're sad, they're going to cry. If they're angry, they might try and bite.
If they're happy, they'll giggle.
But the point is a child at a very young age is almost
definitely authentic.
It is putting forward its feelings as it experiences them.
It is unfiltered. Um, and this is what gives babies their charm,
but also makes them terrifying, quite difficult to,
to look after because they're just doing exactly what they need to do
when they need to do it. There's no process of editing.
And this is a process of engaging with what Donald,
when it got famous child psychoanalyst called the true self.
Now Keefer Winnicott is the idea that if you're going to grow up and be a
balanced and healthy and authentic human being,
you will need to have been given the enormous privilege of expressing
your true self to those around you.
In the very earliest years that you were on the planet,
all of us need to have those moments when we can be totally authentic.
Even at the cost of giving other people a bit of a headache around us,
we need some of this true self,
but Winnicott also observed in his work with children,
that there is a danger that something else happens too soon.
And that is the birth of a false self.
Now the full self is created out of the expectations of everyone around the
small child. And there are all sorts of expectations. Firstly,
that the child will be good, that the child will go to sleep on time.
Which really means on the parents jejunal that the child will smile at Grammy,
that the child will at school be polite to the teacher.
And then going on into later childhood will always follow certain
rules writing. Thank you letters, um, being a good child. Now,
there are obviously good aspects to being a good child,
but Winnicott was very alive to the concept of over early
adaptation. What he called over compliance and for Winnicott,
the over compliant child has all sorts of problems.
What happens is that they are more attuned to the demands of others than to
their own needs.
And this can give them lots of difficulties in later life when they can no
longer be authentic. Um,
they lose touch with what they really want because what they really want has
been censored so heavily by those,
around them in our world now is we know all about rebels and the problem with
rebels. You know,
they're the ones who graffiti the underpass and cause social problems.
And we know how difficult this can be, but through the eyes of Winnicott,
we can also start to see another problem.
And in a way it's perhaps a bigger problem though.
It doesn't present itself as such.
And that is an excess of compliance in a whole group of people that we can
call with nothing pejorative being meant by this, the good boys and girls,
there are good boys and girls everywhere.
And the problem with good boys and girls is they've been good too early.
They haven't got the bad out of their system.
They haven't had a chance to express themselves as they needed to in the early
years,
they weren't able to bite when they wanted to bite to kick when they wanted to
kick to scream and they wanted to scream all the things that little babies and
infants do. And shouldn't frighten anyone by wanting to do,
if all of that is suppressed with too much energy, there will be a problem.
So Winnicott the great patron Saint of being able to get the right
relative claims of the true and the false self, a false self,
we all need one to navigate adult life,
but it only starts to make internal sense if we've also had a chance to express
the true self at another point.
Another great idea from Winnicott is the concept of the good enough parent.
Many parents came to Winnicott,
very worried that they weren't doing a good enough job as parents.
They wanted to be better. They were worried that they weren't educating the kid,
right, or that there was some eating problem or school problem, et cetera.
And when it got could see that these worries were actually getting in the way of
the parents doing, um, that you know, the fairly good job that they were doing.
And so when it got made a fascinating intervention, first of all,
he told parents, no child needs a perfect parent. Indeed.
A perfect parent is very dangerous.
It's a one-way route to psychosis to a psychotic incident because essentially
the job of a parent is to disappoint a child bit by bit and
induct them into adult realities. If the parent is perfect,
how can the child grew used to living in the world that we all have to live in,
which is a deeply imperfect one. So in an ideal world,
a good parent is able to break bad news well to the child
until the child can accept the whole panoply of difficulties of adult life
amounting, ultimately into the fact that we are all mortal,
we are all going to have to die. So, um, Winnicott,
in order to capture what he was trying to tell parents came up with a wonderful
phrase. He said, no one needs a perfect parent.
All they need is a good enough parent. And this phrase,
good enough is the one that Winnicott launched into the world.
And it's a highly useful one because in so many areas we don't need to be
perfect. We just need to be good enough. We only need to be good enough workers,
good enough friends, good enough colleagues. Um, and as I say, good enough, uh,
parents, all of this comes from the very down to earth,
beautifully written and always highly useful and humane wisdom of
Donald Winnicott and his wonderful book home is where we start from
another book. That's very dear to me is by Arthur Schopenhauer.
And it's called essays on the wisdom of life. Now,
Arthur Schopenhauer is perhaps the most pessimistic of all the panoply
of very pessimistic,
German thinkers that philosophy produced in that country.
In the 19th century,
he stands out for the unrelentingly miserable tone of his voice.
He says, at one point it is bad today.
Tomorrow it will be worse until the worst of all happens.
He says at another point that human life is completely ill adapted to its
purposes that no one can expect to be happy ever for more than five minutes at a
time. Um,
and that anyone who expects anything out of romantic love is sure to be
completely disappointed that nothing is true,
that no friends can be constant, um,
that no career ambition will ever come. Right. I mean,
he is the most miserable person on a however,
reading him is a joy. Firstly, he writes beautifully.
He writes beautifully in German.
There's some wonderful translations into English.
And there's something about somebody articulating the most despairing thoughts
that brings us a huge amount of comfort for a start. We think I'm not alone.
All those suspicions. You have often, you know,
three in the morning and despair or, uh, gazing out of the, um,
airplane window and a low moment. And you just think,
what on earth is the point of all this? Well, Schopenhauer has been there.
He's investigated the territory of despair and he's put his flag all over it.
And it is wonderful what he manages to see.
Most of us only glimpse despair out of the corner of our eye.
And we can't bear it. Schopenhauer urges us to look despair in the face,
make friends with it and also laugh defiantly at it.
He's he's all the time sort of grinning slightly as he tells us these dark
dark truths.
So often sadness comes about because we clash into an
expectation of what life should be like.
That is simply contrary to what reality can actually produce and
showing how gently and with real intelligence nudges us towards a
slightly more pessimistic vision of the world. Yes.
Many of your dreams won't come true. Yes.
Probably love won't work out for your probably large aspects of your career. Um,
won't come off. Uh, probably many people will disappoint you.
The world will seem ugly and dumb. Schopenhauer is saying, I know,
I know I've been here, let's cry together rather than alone,
or rather than escaping into a sentimental bromide that,
that shields us from the fundamental reality that we're engaged with.
So this is your man at the moments of real despair.
He is the friend and darkness and oddly,
strangely he is immensely consoling. Um, so these are two books,
uh, by Winnicott home is where we come from and, uh,
by Schopenhauer essays on the wisdom of life that bring immense cheer in very
different ways to the always confusing business of being alive.
Hey guys, this is Tim again, just a few more things before you take off.
Number one, this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird that I've somehow dug up in the,
the world of the esoteric as I do,
it could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared
with my close friends, for instance. And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that, check it out,
just go to four-hour work week.com that's four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you will get the very next word.
And if you sign up, I hope you enjoy it.